good morning
Millennials welcome back to the toast
and happy Wednesday it is hump day very
appropriately because you know the woman
I'd like to hump is sitting right next
to me it's my favorite lesbian Taylor
shuer hey girl hey thank you so much for
being here oh my God I'm so sorry I'm
late you are late and let's talk about
that let's talk about that um listen I
feel like you moved out of the burrow
like a few years ago in the beginning
like we gave you Grace we're like she
lives in Jersey
but you've lived there now for how many
years it's like three and every time you
leave your house it's like the first
time no
it's no this is I'm brid and tunnel that
is what happens that's fine that's fine
you but like you have to acclimate like
get over it I it shouldn't take an hour
to get here listen we're living in
difficult times you know I cannot and I
just feel like honestly I think I speak
for all of our friends when I say like
we're kind of sick of it like you live
in Jersey like that's fine God that's F
it's literally fine but like every time
for it to be like an ordeal and like a
conversation I just think like the
friends wanted me to say something which
friends pretty much all of them you're
like my only friend that lives I know I
like how I'm like all my friends we
literally have Brian literally doesn't
live here um I don't know I feel like I
heard you know marre say something about
it yeah okay okay and like all of our
friends and like Ben is like non-stop
complaining all the time he's livid I
mean but Ben is also late everywhere so
that's why I [__] with Ben and that's
why I feel like you and I are just kind
of connected cuz when I hang out with
you I feel like I'm hanging out with my
slow late
husband I really am sorry you look
beautiful thank you so much for being
here well I wore your favorite cardigan
you have just like a great collection of
Cardigans which I feel is a great thing
to have like yeah they're ma as I call
them Ma May Maj I don't even know how to
say it anymore because you're always
mispronouncing it I can't say mararo you
can't mjar wait no now you're making me
mojarro how do I say it mojarro
moonaro I can't get I really I don't
know how I've existed this long as an
adult yeah it's really um got a grasp on
the language exactly without getting
anywhere on time right right right she's
a troubled woman you look so fabulous I
feel like I don't want to spend the
whole episode today talking about OIC
because we really did like a deep dive
on your podcast and everyone should
listen to it but I don't know how we're
going to function without talking about
OIC ever since I've had my coming out of
the closet party it's been the best
thing ever I mean you no you've really
understood what it feels like to come
out literally literally welcome to the
lgbtqia A Plus Community by the way I'm
kind of like the O in LGBT qo like
AIC or like LGBT F
fat it's not a thing not a thing not but
I do kind of understand the gay
experience now and I'm really sorry for
what you went through that must been
tough yeah it's really hard to keep a
secret isn't it not that it was a secret
right no no but I know what you're
saying like it's difficult you're right
I kind of I'm a lesbian you're literally
a lesbian I have to say it though like I
don't even really know what it's like to
be a lesbian you had a very unique
coming out experience yes I mean I like
can you imagine Keeping a Secret for
your whole life my wife like kept it for
like four years it breaks my heart and
that's small no but especially during
those really difficult like teenage
years High School people kids are so
mean so mean do you feel like that you
didn't have to go through that I really
do and it makes me feel like I need to
like do better as a member of the queer
Community know to like make up for it
know you need to just be nicer to your
wife I am so nice to my wife sure when
was I not nice to my wife no you are you
are I just feel like you could be
nicer we could all be nicer we could all
be nicer that's kind of the message of
today's show okay I like that I will say
this Taye and I we went to go see James
Taylor over the weekend I saw that you
went at PNC I know Ben is obsessed with
James Taylor he actually saw he was like
we should go but honestly like no oh my
God you should have come like I do I've
seen fire and I've seen rain literally
is that not the LIC to every single song
though that he sings yeah what are other
songs that he I was trying to go through
it like recapping and I was like he sang
Fire and Rain he sang a song that also
sounds like Fire and Rain oh but Ben's
favorite song of all time is his song um
and it goes a little something like
um oh [__] Ben sings it all the time
like about a cowboy Oh Sweet Baby James
yes Ben's parents used to sing Sweet
Baby Ben to him like when he was a baby
stop and he there is a young cowboy who
Liv by R his horse and his donkey are
his only companion those aren't the
lyrics his horse and his
Sab miss me someone could
hear so good night Moonlight
Lady my sweet
baby do you want me to show off it's
kind of like my
show remember when I did karaoke and
embarrass myself I mean I don't think
I've ever done karaoke and not embarrass
myself so which time are you talking
about we were with Brian and New Hope of
course we you were phenomenal I did have
a pretty good showing at that karaoke um
place but you were excellent too you
sing Alanis morsa well no no no no we
were excellent together in our duet and
that's when I should have stopped but I
was highe on my own Supply and you were
also really pushy but like the talent at
that place like the bar was so low like
everybody stunk it up it's nice it was
one of those places where there's one
stage like I think sometimes karaoke in
the city especially you get like private
rooms which is fun but this place had
one stage and it was like the whole room
was like in the palm of your hand it was
very exciting no but like you really
thrived I I've been reading a lot lately
not to brag what yes Taylor Jenkins Reed
wait I the way I die for her were you
the one that told me to read the seven
husbands ofo how could you not tell me
you read it oh I'm so sorry so are you
in the middle or you finish it oh I am
done and then I finished I finished
Daisy Jones and now I'm on to Malibu
Rising that's not a that's not her best
book whatever it's fine I just I need I
need to hit okay after this you need to
read um One True Loves is that her yeah
I'm in I'm such I'm a junkie for her
wait I can't believe like for the last
two years I've been trying to get you to
read and then you just started reading
and didn't even tell me so we went out
to LA take out the book at the airport
and I was at the like whatever what's it
called
bookstore and I was like what did
Claudia say what did Claudia say and
then Taye was like I've heard that this
is a good one I'm like I think that
feels like the right one taaye got it
and I kept stealing it and I like could
not put it down I told you you would
love it it's the greatest book ever
written in the history of bookwriting
it's like my top five favorite books so
anyway but she's like Taylor Jenkins
Reed is obsessed with like Beauty and
famous people and every book there's
always like and you just knew when
someone had it and whenever everything
that I think of you oh my god and I
think of the night at karaoke
specifically cuz like I know that you're
a star but like you guys at this place
the way that you were like you were it
wasn't even just that your voice was
good you were really like owning the
stage you were doing crowd work you were
you did selenon which is like who the
[__] does selenon and let's get real you
don't sound like Seline not in the
slightest but you carried yourself like
Seline literally so nice like I'm going
to cry I was really proud of you and I D
duet you can come back on the toast okay
thank you I was late I have to [__]
kiss her butt it's true like I feel like
if anybody knows me the number one way
to my heart is through my ass like
whenever whenever me and Ben will like
come home from like a dinner party or
time be like oh I really liked that girl
he's like yeah obviously like she only
asked you questions about your life and
yourself and she was like up your ass
yeah that's the number one way to be my
friend so toxic munching your butt today
and you know what that completely works
for me I feel like we have a very um
complimentary butt munching relationship
I AG we Munch each other's butt it's
called being a good friend it's so true
we're kind of like the exemplary
friendship I agree
we together we're amazing I think we're
kind of like two of the greatest people
who've ever existed I fully agree and
yes what were you looked like you were
going to say but
but sometimes you love me so much you
pushed me outside of my comfort zone
like reading and that no that's what you
did that night and New Hope and I can't
even hear the name Alanis Morisette
without going like this you know that
that's so crazy to me cuz you literally
sounded fabulous well thank you but I
felt like a big loser and I was trying
so hard there was streaming down my
face like I wasn't crying cuz I was like
moved I was crying from like it was
either crying or pooping you know what
that actually makes a lot of sense I
went with tears um speaking of like
amazing Excellence we're about to
deliver a fabulous episode this is only
day two of toast being back I know oh my
God how exciting for seriously it really
was yesterday was such an exciting day
thank you for being here I'm honored we
have so much pop culture to catch up on
so excited and I just can't wait to get
your takes and it's Wednesday which
means we're going to do deer toasters
and for some reason you are always here
for deer toasters I love deer toasters
well we've got some really Wild Ones
today so I'm glad that you're here me
too and I feel like we should just Dive
Right In cuz do if we don't we'll just
sit here talking about OIC for the next
six hours I know and we won't do that to
you guys but seriously like let us know
if you want like a deep dive episode on
patreon because we'll do it I really
would I can't stop talking about I went
to dinner last night and exact literally
it it came up because there's nothing
else to talk about on the planet besides
OIC somebody else brought it up not even
me it's very interesting it is and I do
love to hear like people's takes on it
their experience like people in their
lives experience and actually last night
I was just talking to a friend and she
said like a bunch of people in her life
were on it and it actually didn't work
for them which I was surprised by really
you know how people like trauma Bond
yeah we ow zic bonded I mean it's
everything like I'm like we we've always
been great friends but I really feel
like this is the thing that really just
like push us over the edge I completely
agree of Sisterhood Sisterhood shots and
Sisterhood well in the words of uh the
professor from Legally Blonde screw
Sisterhood because we have the Fast Five
to get dive into are you ready Taylor do
it baby here are the fast five stories
that you need to know today's episode of
the toast is brought to you by Thrive
Cosmetics Thrive Cosmetics is a fabulous
brand that I actually found I think like
on Facebook a million years ago and now
I use so many of their products I have a
lot of their beauty products in the
studio at home the mascara if you know
you know I always get asked cuz I have
like the worst lashes so tons of
different products their best sellers
are the brilliant eye brighteners so if
you're looking for like an inner corner
highlight or like little under your brow
it's perfect it's so easy to use and
it's so glowy and stunning the hydrating
lip tints we have at Jackie Studio we
have here because I hate when you have
to like sacrifice chap lips for like no
color so their hydrating lip tints have
really beautiful colors but they keep
your lips moisturized and when we're
talking on the podcast you know we're
chatty chatty chatty but for me the pie
resistance from Thrive Cosmetics is
their liquid lash extensions mascara it
has more than 25,000 five star reviews
for a reason I have really straight
lashes that don't hold hold a curl so if
I don't use this mascara I don't look
like I'm wearing eyelash I don't look
like like I'm wearing mascara and it
look like I haven't you know woken up
yet so it mimics the look of lash
extensions without the damaging glue or
Salon prices they use a salon they use a
proprietary tubing formula which means
that it wraps around each lash and you
apply it it'll dramatically lengthen and
Define your lashes from root to tip last
all day without clumping smudging or
flaking and its nourishing ingredients
support longer stronger and healthier
looking lashes over time Thrive
Cosmetics is an amazing brand all of
their products are 100% vegan and
crueltyfree they're made with clean
skin-loving ingredients so that means no
parabens no sulfates no flat lates and
it's all without compromising the
performance of the products their
products are really that good you have
to try Thrive Cosmetics to really see
for yourself and right now you can get
an exclusive 20% off your first order
when you visit Thrive cosmetics.com
toast that's Thrive CA M
tcs.com toast for 20% off your first
order today's episode is also brought to
you by zip recruiter you know if you're
an employer who's hiring the average
cost per hire is
$4,700 so if you're investing that much
money into new each higher you want to
get it right and to get it right you got
to use zip recruiter it's the most
effective way to find the best people
you can see for yourself right now you
can try it for free when you go to
ziprecruiter.com toast you'll experience
the value that zip recruiter brings to
hiring so what's so great about zip
recruiter why is it not like others it's
because they let you try before you
commit there's no cost to zip recruiter
when you're trying it you can post jobs
for free and you can see for yourself
how effective zip recruiter is at
helping you hire they also help you find
more qualified candidates faster their
technology Works quickly to identify
people people whose skills and
experience match your job they'll also
send you a list of available uh great
matches for your job so you can review
the top ones and the best part is that
they give you the power to zero in on
top talent so if you have your eye on an
excellent candidate they let you reach
out to them you can easily send
candidates you're really interested in a
personal invitation to apply it'll help
your job stand out so zip recruiter
helps you get hiring right four out of
five employers who post on zip recruiter
get a quality candidate within the first
day see for yourself go to
ziprecruiter.com for free um when you go
to zip recruiter rec.com toast you'll be
able to try it for free at zippr
recruiter.com toast zip recruiter the
smartest way to hire another the big
news of the day it's an update from
yesterday but you know a lot of us were
in disbelief a lot of us were in denial
but as of this morning with the very you
know lowbudget Instagram story
screenshot statement from Joe Jonas and
Sophie Turner I know they're officially
uh calling for a divorce and they're
calling it a United decision in their
first statement since the breakup not
true so it's officially jover Joe Jonas
and Sophie Turner released a joint
statement when wednes day to publicly
address their divorce for the first time
after four wonderful years of marriage
we have mutually decided to amicably end
our marriage there are many speculative
narratives as to why but truly this is a
United decision and we sincerely hope
that everyone can respect our wishes for
privacy for us and our children the
statement came one day after Joe filed
for divorce from Sophie he did it in a
Miami Court stating uh that their Union
was irretrievably broken um the Jonas
Brother member also claimed in the
filing that his and the and Sophie
Turner
two daughters have primarily been living
with him but he is seeking shared
parental responsibility after the split
a source Clos to the Jonas family told
page six exclusively that divorce was a
last resort for Joe he never wanted to
break up his family but had to take what
he felt was the best course of action
for his girls Joe finally reached a
point where he felt that he had
exhausted all options to salvage the
marriage now I have so many thoughts on
this but it's very clear everything in
the media has been from Joe's Camp you
know absolutely the kids are with him
she the insinuation has been like kind
of a like a damaging accusation that
she's partying and not present with the
kids and it's all alleged and it's all
coming from his camp but and so that
would make me think that there's
actually like very bad blood between
them if they're taking it to the Press
but she The Last Resort right but she
was just at his show I know well this is
the thing too it's like can we even
trust Joe I don't know because so all
these Whispers where there's smoke
there's fire and then he comes out on
stage wearing his wedding ring which he
had been not wearing previously Sophie
is there and then he chooses to sing
this s that he actually wrote about her
which puts to bed and like why are you
going to do this dog and pony show two
days later yes no it's very this whole
thing has been like really messy I feel
like it got out before I think they were
planning on getting divorced and like
having it be handled quietly and then
once it all came out like releasing a
statement but I think like TMZ got a tip
or something okay and it threw their
whole P strategy into but then why like
put on this like performance of like
we're in love and here and my Ring's on
and I'm singing this song and he posted
on Instagram a photo and his ring was
like literally front and center like hey
well it made me feel like there was an
opportunity where maybe she was like
begging crying like please please please
get back together please please please
let's do this to save face but like then
what between that action like and the
fact that he said it was or his camp or
whoever a last resort like so what does
that mean she is she I know they're
implying that she is a drinking problem
they are they're part implying that
she's like a party girl who's not you
know who's neglecting her parental
responsibility but you know what I feel
like she's 27 I mean by the way that
could be entirely true it's all alleged
but it's so unfair to judge everything
thus far has come from Joe's POV and
how's Joe coming out of this
hardworking parent number one taking the
girls on tour non-stop work non-stop
parent it's like okay well we need to
hear from Sophie because it's easy for
her to be painted in this light she
hasn't said anything she hasn't her team
hasn't put out any TMZ exclusives I just
saw a story on page six that said that
she was like seen out drink guzzling
drinks to buzzling drinks Downing drinks
at a bar but two days before the divorce
was announced like do you know what I
look like when I got a divorce oh you
know what yeah speak from your
experience I was a human keg existing I
was just trying to survive like she's
allowed to guzzle drinks and I'm sure
she was having like three martinis which
for me is just a Tuesday a Tuesday well
I feel so bad for her I also like have
so many questions about the format of
this divorce like this is I mean this
statement this is a divorce it's not you
know a small thing it's a big PR and
they literally you know it was an
Instagram story that was screenshotted
and then posted in feed it was like the
Instagram font it wasn't um it didn't
appear to be particularly thoughtful in
terms of its content or its design no
and that was particularly shocking to me
and like at the top of it it was like
statement from both of us and it's like
well a publicist would you know sign at
Joe and Sophie Turner and then they
would both post it on their Instagram it
would be clear that it was a joint
statement but to have at the top be like
statement from both of us like it was
just very um low budget yeah I was
surprised cuz they're two like real
a-listers I know this was not aess
Behavior this whole thing is very messy
very not aess do you think we're going
to find out like is this where it ends
and we'll hear nothing else or do you
think we're going to get like the tea
not to be disgusting no I actually don't
think we're going to get the tea because
of their kids and they are two
celebrities we've never seen a photo of
their kids they've never even released
the name of their second child right so
they're Uber private when it comes to
their family and this is Family Matters
and I actually don't think this will be
a thing we just wonder about for years
to come that's what I think I almost
feel like the truth would be better for
Sophie's like image because I think that
right now what's to speculate is and
it's nasty and it's just yeah we're
getting a few things you know the kids
are with Joe she was at a bar like then
that leads people to come to conclusions
of their own which is not and also the
wording of the reason for the divorce
was IR what the the marriage I've never
heard this word before yeah actually I
had a hard time pronouncing it
irretrievably broken that sounds like
she cheated if he's the one that filed
I'm just saying right no the thing is
everything thus far has weirdly been his
control yeah he's the one who filed he's
the it's his POV that's coming out in
TMZ and Page T like yeah hash where is
Sophie Turner and he got like a really
scary ass lawyer yeah I'm worried for
Sophie I know but she's rich don't worry
should be okay yeah she's got that Game
of Thrones money I think that's like
like is that forever money I don't know
if it's forever money but she was you
know a principal character if you did
you watch the show yeah uh yeah so many
people were on the show not all of them
were as famous as her and not all of
them lasted everyone was dying on the
show very few characters actually made
it from episode one to episode you know
50 very true and she's one of them now I
don't think she and and this is
something actually Jack and I feel like
spoke about privately for as famous as
that show made a lot of people there
aren't I would say honestly the only one
who had work bigger than Game of Thrones
afterwards is Jason Mamoa with Aquaman
absolutely none of them really had like
crazy Blockbuster moments right Amilia
Clark she's so famous but like that one
movie with you know the guy in the
wheelchair but there like she doesn't
have like crazy success after the show
right I don't know if really any of them
do except that's why I'm worried about
Sophie like yeah I hope she made a [__]
ton of money cuz what has she done since
she has had cameos in a few movies and I
know she did like a quibby thing
everyone was doing quibby at the time
quibby yeah but I don't know that's a
good question yeah I'm nervous I'm
nervous for her I I really I wish her
well they were one of my real favorite
like celebrity couples and they were a
celebrity couple I didn't worry about I
know so for them to have just come out I
actually when you know when you're
reading something like sometimes like a
celebrity dies like you're reading it
but you can't process it for like 30
seconds I was like wait no this can't
possibly be I uh I mean I'm a narcissist
so every time like a couple gets
divorced I just think about me and Tay
of course but it's like God does anybody
[__] make it anymore it's so
disheartening spoken as a divorce a
right but like you know I want to
believe in forever but these celebrity
couples they just really they're like
very bad PR for the brand of marriage
but I don't think you should put like
any personal stake in Celebrity
marriages like celebrity is so toxic
there's so many bad influences why why
do you think it is that Fame and
partying and money it destroys people
even like the happiest person Fame can
be really really like toxic and negative
yeah and it's like an addiction it's
like it's like drugs you need to be like
a really really grounded person to like
survive that level of Fame and that
level of access to like money and drugs
and alcohol like you it's not built for
the faint of heart I know but like you
know it's like my dream to always be a
housewife of course so if like and I
always say if the opportunity came I'd
never be strong enough to say no I even
though I would be fearful that it would
ruin everything that level of Fame I
think is manageable that's not like I'm
talking about like hardcore Hollywood
these two are very Hollywood they're
very he's in like a huge touring band
they're touring stadiums she's a part of
like this iconic franchise she's really
like an a-lister this is next level so
it's possible that that's what happened
it's possible that the fame had nothing
to do with it I don't know right we'll
never know I need to know it's killing
me I might have to go to the place I
never go reddit reddit but Reddit knows
nothing they do know nothing no and I
just want to say like I like tried like
I know some people and like I was like
being a snoop I'm like I need to know
nobody knows what happened like I was
being a Sno they're private people
nobody knows I didn't get any
information which was really like tough
for me I'm really sorry about that I
know um okay our next story is hilarious
so we reported yesterday Timothy shamay
and Kylie Jenner are like 100% confirmed
those videos of them at Beyonce very
ious yes but the internet has found like
the Tim okay let me rephrase that people
have discovered the rabbit hole NOP
people have discovered the corner of the
internet that is like the shalamay fan
club okay and these people are losing
their minds and it's the funniest thing
okay well they're all medieval leather
shoes okay just like their leader Tim so
the Timothy shami fans are calling Kylie
Jenner a stalker after the pair is seen
kissing so the internet has gone crazy
of course after the videos of Timothy
shalamay and Kylie Jenner were spotted
kissing at a Beyonce concert so it came
months after speculation that the two
had become an item but some are
seemingly more upset than others about
the pair namely um Club shalam that's
what the internet is calling them this
like corner of the internet okay um so a
woman named Simone who calls herself a
gen xla based super fan account um she
has called Kylie Jenner a stalker she
says it looks like they're meeting for
the first time since she's been stalking
his place what else is he supposed to do
spit in her face he was probably there
with friends and Mama carner waved her
staff and commanded this meeting be
filmed the literal the shalamay fans are
depressed they're supporting one another
during this dark time being like guys
it's okay go to sleep like we need to
just get some sleep maybe when we wake
up it'll all be over people being like I
really hope he's wearing a condom like
the shalam fans are not [__] okay I
didn't even know there was like a shalam
he's an actor not like a K-pop Star I
didn't know he had like a shalam AR
I will say it's very interesting so a
good friend of mine is obsessed with Tim
shalam Tim and I like I like he
literally is a human equivalent of a
medieval leather shoe like it really is
crazy did you ever see that Meme of
Kylie and Tim in the bathtub together
no it was a picture of like like fit
shapely legs and then like these like
little tiny pale bony legs do you think
he weighs over 100 lb no he's definitely
a size Zer in lady's jeans literally and
but like my friends that are obsessed
with him like I'll be like I don't
really get this is Prett KY by the way I
don't get it I'm like I don't get it it
also feels creepy like he looks 12
perpetually and the way they get so
angry with me and they're like have you
seen call me by your name and I'm like
yeah I have and I'm also a gay so like
I'm allowed to not like that movie and
guess what she don't like the movie oh
wow I never saw it also Army Hammer like
do we even need to but like it's just
like I didn't love the story I just like
wasn't here for the timate of it all
okay but you're L but weirdly now I said
the same thing yesterday I am doing this
thing where I am so like I'm like timate
not good for your brand this Kylie thing
oh oh my God I was going to say like I
actually understand the hype people have
thought he was so hot he's like so many
people celebrity crushes when I tell you
I never understood it in my life yes
seeing the Kylie video I'm like okay you
know what homeboy can get it like I I
could understand it I don't agree with
it but I can understand it and I
actually thought like they looked really
cute and sexy together I don't like them
together they're mismatched and it's not
that one's better than the other well
okay here's the thing I mean Kylie is a
star Kylie is a billionaire like Kylie
is definitely like like he is taking a
major leap up I feel like but he just
gives me like I'm a serious actor I
write poetry like they just like don't
make sense they don't feel like a match
no but I feel like everyone freaking out
like this is just the Classic thing
where people just like hate the
Kardashians for no reason and it's like
like okay why like she didn't do
anything wrong she went to a concert
with her boyfriend like and it's cute
you know what and they are cute they are
like I'm telling you I thought I thought
the videos were like sexy and cute yeah
they're very into each other I know
isn't that nice I actually saw like a
someone uh who's like a professional lip
reader reading like some of their
conversation and it sounded like he said
I love you they've been together for a
minute right this rumor started like a
decently long time ago and it's been
true ever since that's not a crazy
amount of time to tell tell someone you
love them not at all no they're really
into each other and I don't know I just
think the fact that everybody's like
rejecting this like makes me like it I
get that like there's nothing wrong with
Kylie she's a nice business girl you
know she's a smart family oriented Queen
she just feels like Kim's AI do you know
what I'm saying that's actually an
amazing call thank you and so I just
feel like what do they talk about he
feels deep she feels not I'm not trying
to be a [__] but like not deep that's
the way I'll say it okay but you know
what I feel like that is just like your
deeped you know misogyny like why is she
not deep she started a billion dollar
company right we don't really know her
she's never on the show and I think
that's the whole point of her brand is
like she said this many times like
nobody really knows me she's actually
like very weird and outgoing but like we
see her on the show she says four words
right and you know we see her on
Instagram and it's just like photos of
herself we don't know her so I think the
conclusion that she's not deep is it
could be true but we have no proof of
that or maybe it's also by Design not
that she's not deep but we just don't
know her at all her image that she's
putting out she's mysterious but it is
weird that she's like a mom of two and
he's like a child that's the other thing
she well oh my God is she his babysitter
no right literally like he visually like
it doesn't make sense to me yeah for the
first time ever next to her he look like
a man yes oh my God you know what that's
what it is he's like having a bar
mitzvah like he was growing up right in
front of our eyes wait the movie you're
so not did you watch Claudia yes of
course I did I loved it was so good it
was so sweet and I felt like it actually
really celebrated the Jewish faith yes
so much of like the Jewish experience on
Netflix is like EXT in my opinion like
actually offensive yes I thought this
was so sweet it was so nice to see like
the normalization of Bot Mitzvah culture
and it wasn't offensive his daughters
were amazing they were so good beautiful
girls I love that his wife was in it and
it was just a me and Ben were cackling
and it was very on point like if you've
gone through the bot Mitzvah years as a
teenager like that girl Sarah Sherman
from SNL who played the female like
conservative Rabbi first but let me tell
you like that person exists like yeah it
was a Flawless performance of like a
conservative sh female Rabbi like it
would the vest the yaka the treadmill
like it was perfect I loved the movie um
I'm going to I'm the worst bot is girl
bar is boy okay yes I'm going to a bot
Mitzvah like in a month I'm so excited I
Haven been to a bot Mitzvah or bar
mitzvah in years who's Dr wider she's on
my show every single day or every every
single day every single week and her
daughter Piper that's so sweet who I'm
obsessed with oh that's so nice so
excited and you know like Bart MIT are
incredibly underrated because as a kid
you know I used to go to them once a
week for like two years and I was 13 and
I was like looking forward to of course
like hanging out with boys and stuff but
as an adult like they're fully open bar
fully and like it's just a dance floor
and a bar mhm it's fun it's like a
wedding without any of the Annoying [__]
without right right are you going to go
to like the the sh part I would like to
it's nice to see like a girl become a
woman and also like the singing it's
beautiful it's beautiful I love that for
real I know I'm so excited um well Tim
and his Army of fans like you're going
to be okay but honestly it's one of the
funniest things I've seen like people
having like actual like they're in
crisis mode yes they they can't believe
it I understand why they're having a
hard time processing because it doesn't
really make sense but like we just have
to like let go and let godone yeah I
wonder if they have these same types of
reactions he's been spotted out with
like a few ladies remember he was making
out in a pool with Asa Gonzalez I wonder
how they handled that do they just not
want Tim to date anyone because they're
in love with him or is it Kylie I think
it's a combination of the two I think
it's a combination of the two as well I
do today's episode is also brought to
you by Thrive Market Thrive Market is
our go-to for all of our our organic
grocery and household essentials and the
convenience of getting it all quickly
shipped to our doorstep is a huge
timesaver Jackie and I have always been
a fan big fan of grocery delivery and
Nobody Does it Better Than Thrive Market
they have the best products for me the
best part of Thrive Market is
discovering new brands and new products
that you never would have found if it
weren't for Thrive market like I didn't
even know Annie's made these cheese
puffs that are so good Jackie bought
them for Harry one time and now they are
a staple in my order so as a Thrive
Market member you're saving money on
every single order on average we are
saving over 30% each time and on top of
those massive savings Thrive Market has
a deals page it changes daily you can
get cash back on so many Brands they
have a price match guarantee so they're
always keeping your pocket in mind which
I really appreciate not only do they
save us money they also save us time the
filters on their websites we love so if
you're looking for like certified
gluten-free snacks or non-toxic cleaning
Essentials you can sort by using those
filters and it's so much faster so much
easier and you're going to get what you
need with the click of a button you can
trust that all the products are made the
with the highest quality ingredients and
sourcing methods and when you join
Thrive Market you're helping a family in
need with their one forone membership
matching program you join and they give
so join in on the savings with Thrive
market today and get 30% off your first
order plus a free $60 gift go to
thrivemarket.com theeast for 30% off
your first order plus a free $60 gift
that's th r i v
market.com theeast Thrive
market.com t h t a s thrivemarket.com
the toast today's episode is also
brought to you by canva a favorite brand
here at the toast we are a Content
machine you know if you scroll down to
our Instagram like from the beginning
you'll see our content used to not be
good you know we didn't know about canva
back then and honestly you could tell
canva is so great for creating visual
content it's essential part of what we
do you know social media Graphics videos
things like that the creative process
hasn't always been this easy but we
found canva for teams and it has been
easy to collaborate and design with our
team which makes the whole process so
much more fun and creative so it's a
design platform that makes it easy for
anyone to create stunning content in any
format from social media posts to videos
presentations websites the endless
templates and premium fonts photos
graphics and videos that they offer add
personality and Edge to our content with
features designed for brand consistency
canva for teams makes it easy to
maintain your aesthetic and add your
logos fonts and colors to anything you
create they streamline how we do social
media too you can plan create and share
social media content directly from all
of our channels in one place and the
best part is they let you schedule
social media posts ahead of time so if
you working social or you have like a
side hustle it's so easy to schedule and
create content on canva for teams um and
also if you create a lot of
presentations those can be like really
hard for no reason you know you create a
deck canvas so easy you'll have like a
stunning looking deck it looks like you
paid someone a lot of money but it's
just canva for teams you know
collaborate with canva for teams right
now you can get a free 45-day extended
trial when you go to canva do me/ toast
that's CV
a.me toast for a free 45-day extended
trial can. me/ toast all right our next
story um is another update Drew
Barrymore gate she has this stalker that
video that went viral a few weeks ago we
actually talked about it on your podcast
Chad Michael boow her stalker yeah by
the way I got that name wrong yeah you
were so right and I was so wrong because
I remember reading it and being like
Chad Michael Murray right but it's Chad
Michael boo buo he stormed the Basel at
the 92nd Street y scaring the hell out
of everyone and now he has a warrn out
for his arrest because he failed to show
up to get his GPS monitor fitted so
a warrant has been issued for the arrest
of Chad Michael buo the man accused of
stalking Drew Barrymore after he didn't
appear to get his GPS monitor affixed to
his person so in Southampton a judge
issued a bench warrant for him after he
didn't show up um for the GPS monitor
fitting so the GPS was a conditional
after boo was taken into custody in late
August after he showed up at Drew Barry
home it was because of that it was
because it was actually because he
showed up at her home in Long Island
without invitation days after the 92nd
Street wi speaking engagement gig oh my
God I missed that so he was taken into
custody after officials said that he was
seen scouring her Hampton's neighborhood
looking for the $6 million home that she
lives in Barry Moore was not at the
residence thank God at the time that he
was apprehended there on August 21st two
days before he was arrested he had the
92nd Street y thing so it was 92nd
Street yde two days later arrested in
Southampton for looking you know being
at her home and then he was supposed to
show up and get like a GPS monitor a fix
to his like ankle or his wrist and he
didn't show up and so now there's a
warrant out for his arrest and he's like
he's just like we don't know he's in the
in the wind scary it's actually really
scary for
um Drew drewmore I feel like we see a
lot of celebrity yeah stalkers but like
they always get what's coming to them
like they get arrested they get the
restraining order they get you know the
warrants but for him to be like totally
missing that's freaky as [__] I hope
Drew baramore is like literally locked
in a padded cell like a very luxurious
one where she just can't be touched
that's she must have nonstop security
right now no and this guy was like
posting on social media and he's really
unwell and he just looks crazy has like
a big bruise on his forehead like he's
where he get that bruise on his forehead
I don't know he's deeply unwell he's
deeply unwell like this is so scary this
is like I feel like every celebrity's
worst nightmare yeah when this person
can't even be apprehended oh God I'm
worried for Drew and his name being Chad
Michael boo just takes this whole
situation to another level he was so he
was so familiar it was so unnerving like
true so much to the point that she was
like I think she really thought it was
somebody she knew like a number one fan
or something exactly no it's a like and
I think this is you know a part of like
toxic fan culture but obsession is a
mental illness absolutely and this is
really like an extreme example of that
where do you think he do you think he's
still in the Hamptons no do you think we
should do like a man hunt for him oh my
god let's all put together a search
party to protect Drew I mean we live in
like the age of we all have like I mean
security how can we not find Chad
michelo yes no like literally where in
the world is Chad michelo where is he
where could he be I wonder I feel like a
person like this who he's probably round
swamp getting chicken salad or like the
$45 chicken fingers wow you just made me
so hungry it's the best round swamp is
so good I actually only went there for
the first time recently did you end up
going out to The Hamptons by the way
when remember we were talking about
going to monok I didn't you didn't okay
you I was going to have pH but the last
time I was in the Hamptons I did go to
round swamp which has gone like viral on
Tik Tok it's like this Shack there's a
few of them in the Hamptons but it
literally looks like like a cottage and
you go inside and it is just filled with
like the most delicious pre-prepared
foods veggies desserts oh my God I had
this crumb cake muffin wow I'm starving
right now cuz it's day seven of my OIC I
took it this morning oh I took it
yesterday yeah okay so it's kind of like
worn off you know Wednesday Tuesdays and
Wednesdays are like days where I have to
really fight my natural instinct to be a
beast yes and then come Thursday Friday
um like literally a model like Victoria
Secret where are you oh a little fun
fact I learned cuz now that I been like
talking so much about OIC my phone
definitely knows I'm on OIC and I've LED
on like monjaro talk no way and I get a
bunch of good tips and tricks from the
girlies whose lies have been change like
I meet girls who have been on it for 2
three years and they've maintained their
weight and what do they say what are the
tips and tricks so if you feel like
you've kind of for me I've always
injected in my stomach because they say
you have to just inject it in a
concentrated area of fat and for me
that's always been my stomach um but
someone was like and these are just
girls who speak from their own
experience they're not doctors or
anything they were like you know if
you've uh experienced like a little bit
of a stall
try changing it up and your arm can be
very effective so I'm now my second week
doing arm and I lost two pounds this
week like no [__] yeah changing it up
can change I think the efficacy
according to just some people's
experience I do my stomach I do my booty
you oh you booty I've never done well T
does my booty I can't do my own booty
that would be insane yeah that's what am
I double jointed I've never tried booty
maybe I'll try that next week Booty's
fabulous yeah I always did leg then
stomach never done leg I'm scared of
that fmal artery or whatever is there oh
interesting yeah okay we keep me updated
I will keep you updated now let going
from Chad Michael boo to OIC that's the
thing OIC is like this Universal topic
and also we everyone's like you're not
on OIC I am on a trpp tide if we want to
get technical right I actually am on OIC
but I was I was on semic glutide for the
better part of a year right all right
this next story is something I've been
dying to talk about I'm sure everyone by
now has seen that incredibly bizarre
unnerving quite frightening video of
Taylor Armstrong caught by the paparazzi
outside of Craigs La well she is is now
laughing off the viral moment she went
on watch happin live last night and um
she joked that she's in Disguise to
avoid people recognizing her from her
oddly boisterous Paparazzi video that
went viral last month so Andy asked her
on watch Trappin live whether she had
been you know a smidge over served
perhaps at Craigs in West Hollywood she
said what are you talking about Andy you
know I cut my hair so they wouldn't
recognize me when I leave Craigs
apparently two olives in a Martini is
not dinner the Bravo Le made headlines
after putting on an extremely bizarre
show for the cameras outside the
celebrity hotspot on August 23rd If you
haven't seen the like please go watch it
she's literally not speaking English
she's slurring there's two Paparazzi and
like one of them there doesn't know who
she is so she's like fighting with him
like I'm wearing orange you don't know
where I'm from I'm hot like it's literal
theater it's a work of art uhhuh she's
so Twisted I actually don't know if I've
really ever been that drunk in my life
like it's insane it was honestly it was
a thing of beauty so if I were a
housewife and I went to Craigs and I had
my two martinis and I came outside and
Pap rat didn't know me that is exactly
how I behave she's my spirit animal no
no no I know better but I can't help
myself we've got a reunion we're hot we
were in La for sau's baby shower oh yeah
Paparazzi was there when we walked in
they were like Stacey you look beautiful
and I'm really sick of Daily Mail like
ignoring you no literally cutting me out
of pictures talk straight to camera tell
them there's ignoring me and then
there's like they go out of their way
like chop my face in half like at her
wedding I'm the officient they chop my
face in half that's disgusting it's
disgusting like who do I know that hates
me that works for the Daily Mail who did
you bully in Middle School who now is
like the editor at Daily Mail somebody
yeah so anyway um the paparazzi guy said
Stasi you look gorgeous and I went like
this I'm Taylor strier you
did what did he say he laughed Okay and
like I'm so deranged and
you're Taylor Armstrong in the making
literally Taylor shreer Armstrong you
got a queen oh my God I was obsess model
with this video like a ro model she's a
role model I I also love that she's just
like laughing it off and like not taking
herself too seriously I think she's like
really just happy to be back in like the
Bravo universe and in the Limelight and
she's having fun but this video best it
actually changed my life it made me like
her cuz I've like really disliked her
forever it act it kind of humanized her
like we've all just been drunk she's a
silly drunk girly she's silly
her husband liked it which I loved I
agree I'm not watching this new season
so I don't know much about their
marriage but based on that you don't to
see anything about the marriage I feel
like they actually have a good marriage
they've been married for a really long
time I feel like she went through a
really dark period found him and then
like lived a quiet life and now she's
ready to come back like she's healed um
and he just stood there even though she
was acting like a nut and he just
supported her and you know what I agree
like it actually really made me like him
yep he laughed he wasn't like cuz it'd
be so easy to be like honey let's go go
let's go and get mad but like he just
let her be the drunk freak that she was
being and she didn't say anything bad or
embarrassing she was just being silly
goofy tayor I love her I love her
too our fifth and final story is a story
I also am obsessed with it's another
Housewives adjacent story but it has
nothing to do with like actual
Housewives Taylor Taylor Teresa judice
oh God is being slammed for taking a
photo at Starbucks in Switzerland while
on a trip with her husband Lise so
Teresa indulged in a little piece of
America while traveling abroad she
shared a photo on Instagram on Monday
that showed that she ordered strawberry
assai refresher at Starbucks on her and
her husband's trip to Switzerland in a
slideshow from the getaway a city known
for its medieval architecture she posted
a snap in front of Starbucks and the
comments were having a field day imagine
going all the way to Switzerland and
hitting the Starbucks how about when
you're in another another country you
just eat their food drink their drinks
live like they do and immerse yourself
in their culture get Starbucks when
you're home however a third user who did
not see what was wrong with the photo
rhetorically asked is Switzerland famous
for its coffee it's not if not it's not
okay to go to an internationally
recognized place for coffee question Mar
so let me just say that this is the most
Teresa thing ever like one thing about
Teresa is that she's never pretended to
be someone she's not like she is a tacky
[__] like she is a jersey Queen did you
see her hair at her wedding are you
really surprised she went to Starbucks
in Switzerland and I hate these people
who are so like hoyy toyy like [__]
about traveling like I would just rather
have like the Swiss like just shut up
like Brian our best friend who is
literally a traveling Guru I would think
I think he would say there's nothing
wrong with going Starbucks I'm sure he's
gone to Starbucks in a country that's
even famous for coffee like we like what
we like and it's what's wrong with it we
had McDonald's and Lisbon every single
night so true that's more so and I'll
late night no well that we were drunk
but also like just personally like
Portuguese food was not for me yes cuz
I'm a very particular eater even though
I meant to tell you I tried caviar last
night and I actually liked it oh my God
I had tried caviar so I went I actually
tried caviar at the
Mark like a month ago okay it was for my
birthday we had I had a family dinner
and caviar was on the table I'm like you
know what let me try it yep and I
literally thought it was disgusting it
was really like salt watery is that what
it tastes like I mean yes it also
depends like on which kind you're
getting for sure so then last night I
went to the Mark again but I went to
caviar caspia at the Mark which is like
a caviar restaurant okay and um one of
the appetizers was like a caviar pizza
so it was like a pizza but it was made
of like it was kind of like a potato
lotka y like really thin crispy potato
and just little dollops of caviar and I
don't know if there was like a lot of
butter on the potato but I felt like I
was eating just butter
is that what cavar tastes like no no it
is it's like like when it's the good
good it's like Smooth butter not that
you would know from my birthday party
cuz you were so busy shoveling it onto
Margo and BPL with a metal spoon yeah I
did listen I'm like Teresa I'm like
disgusting and tacky and American like
and I'm proud of that I hate when people
look down I'm like oh Americans like
[__] you [__] we're the greatest
country on Earth eat my ass
[__] who do you think invented
Starbucks that's in all your little
[__] countries we did [__] an
American Howard Schultz I was going to
say with Teresa it's like you can't take
the girl I mean you can take her out of
Jersey but you can't take the Jersey out
of the girl that's perfect but with
Teresa I have to say I love to drag her
but I am so on her side with this first
of all in Europe in case you've been to
Europe you might not know this but they
do not have iced coffee anywhere it's
the weirdest thing so like thank God for
a Starbucks oh my God you know you just
made me crave wow I'm like really hungry
this morning you know you just made me
crave iced coffee in Israel is very
different have you ever had it never so
it's basically all the makings of like
iced coffee you know coffee cream sugar
whatever but they blend it so it it
looks like a milkshake oo and they serve
it everywhere like bodegas like hot dog
carts on the street like they serve it
everywhere and everywhere like the
dirtier and cheaper the better it I'm
sure it has like a th000 calories it
doesn't matter it's the best thing is
real right now wow I've actually never
wanted something more than I want that
right now go get a coffee yum yep um so
one thing I actually never have Teresa
side but I fully have her back in this
like too leave Teresa alone The Taking
of the picture was dumb okay yeah I mean
I wouldn't put it on instam look oh my
God that's good thanks I've been
practicing that's really good did you
learn that from Andrea Lopez I did learn
from Andrea Lopez she's so good oh my
God that was really good thanks girl I
agree I probably wouldn't have put it on
my Instagram but the thing is I'm not
terresa judai so I have to live with
that like why why do they want to did
you did you see those pictures um it was
like it went viral a couple for their
wedding Olive Garden Olive Garden Taylor
that literally went viral probably four
years ago it did not no actually four
years ago four weeks ago no okay ready
like I let me tell you cuz I saw that
people were talking about this Olive
Garden thing again I'm like this was
literally four years ago that's so on
brand for me Olive Garden engagement
shoot people this couple took a their
engagement photos outside of an Olive
Garden and people thought that it was
Italy so this article which is hilarious
but I just thought it recently happened
this is from 201
22 that's a year ago oh you want to know
why they're getting married next month
okay okay maybe that's why everyone's
talking about it again but it was a year
ago you know you know I'm trying with
Tik Tok and everything I know and it
says I'm Tik tok's granny because like
hello am I your granny yeah but tast
said it's confusing because I look so
young well she's your wife you're such a
[__] [__] no I'm kidding you
literally look 12 if you're like Tim oh
my God thank you you should date Tim I
should date Tim appropriate relation
[Laughter]
well those were the Fast Five but
thankfully we are not done yet because
today is Wednesday and we do our weekly
advice segment called deer toasters on
Wednesdays deer toasters is brought to
you by Caraway Caraway cookware is
non-toxic and chemical free so you can
fill your summer with your favorite
recipes without worry so they make
cookware with the convenience of
non-stick so that means without the
concerns of toxic forever chemicals
seeping into your ingredients you're
getting the Best of Both Worlds so of
course you know what do we know about
carway stunning you know if we're we're
putting it in our kitchen it's going to
be gorgeous and we could take cute
photos of it and that's really one of
the best things about it but also the
benefits of the non-toxic are huge um
and non-stick so I feel like sometimes
if you you know you're getting non-stick
cookware you have to compromise with
some you know not so great ingredients
in there but carway has it all their
internet famous kitchen wear is a staple
for any home it comes a variety of
modern Shades to fit with any design
aesthetic so their non-stick chemical
free ceramic coating makes for easy
cooking and clean up their non-toxic
kitchen wear means that food can be
prepared with a peace of mind no knowing
that no hardto pronounce chemicals are
going to be leeching into your healthy
ingredients all of their sets come
equipped with complimentary easy access
storage solutions to keep the kitchen
tidy for me that's the best part I don't
have a big kitchen you know I got a ton
of drawers and cabinets for all these
big pots and pans but the way carway has
like seamlessly designed all of their
products the lids are perfect they store
perfectly in my I have like one big
drawer of pots it works so well and it's
really worth the hype in my opinion so
visit Caraway home.com toast10 to get
10% off your next purchase that's 10%
off at Caraway home.com toast10 or you
can just use code toast 10 a check out
that's t o a s T1 Z carway non-toxic
cookware made Modern so if you want to
write in uh you can always write into to
your girls it's totally Anonymous you
can either email us de your toasters
gmail.com or head over to our website
the toast podcast.com and there's a
little submission box there you can
write in you know your hopes dreams and
wishes to get advice from your girlies
today is very interesting I'm actually
very excited about the first one okay
okay hey guys I won the lottery a little
less than a year ago not the recent
billion dollar jackpot but it was still
a multi-million dollar jackpot it's
exciting and I'm very grateful I've
tried really hard to keep this secret
just to protect myself especially in my
dating life thankfully my state allows
winners to stay Anonymous my immediate
family knows so it's not like I'm lying
to um it's not like I'm dying to tell
anyone else I'm not a showy person so
just people don't know I started daating
a guy a few months ago and things are
getting serious I've been struggling
with whether I should tell him my big
secret we've opened up to each other
about other things so I feel a little
bad holding this back on the one hand
hand winning the lottery is a really big
deal in my life and I want to share all
the significant things in my life with
my boyfriend I worry that relationships
can't last or get to the next level if
either person is keeping secrets from
their partner I also don't want him to
find out too late and then be upset that
I didn't trust him enough until tell him
sooner but I also want to be responsible
and protect myself do you think I should
just tell him now if not at what point
in a relationship would be a good time
to say something I'm torn so I'm very
curious what you girls think thanks for
the advice first of all I can't believe
all I do is talk about the lottery I
can't believe somebody who listens to my
show won the lottery like SU I'm so
jealous I'm so happy for you like for
real like that's major je that's a dream
that's a dream it's literally the
American dream but but like Fame as we
said earlier there is a curse that comes
along with this and I just want to say
you sound really smart and like the fact
that you chose to stay Anonymous and
that you don't tell people like I think
it's 100% the right thing to do like
keep doing that I need to know how much
money you have she said multi-million so
I want to say let's guess I'm going to
say between five and 10 I like to count
people's money me too it's favorite
thing in the world um okay okay okay so
let's say 10 okay easy math so that's
life changing money lifechanging money
you can live off I'm assuming
investments in dividends for like ever
but like at a at like a a normal iser
level right yeah it depends what kind of
life you're leading it sounds like she
didn't change anything in her life she
just kept the money and which is really
smart you know people who win you know a
couple million dollars then buy houses
and boats and in a year's time they're
broke it sounds like you're being so
responsible like I feel like I'm so
proud of you I'm impressed honestly like
keep your life small you know you don't
have to ever worry about paying rent but
like don't buy the biggest house in the
yard like just be smart and I feel like
that's what you're doing and I'm really
proud of you and honestly I really feel
like keeping it from someone is the
smart thing to do you said you've been
together for a few months that makes me
think like 3 to five months I feel like
okay I'm trying to think about like
major things that like have happened
like in my life for like I'm thinking
about like my parents and like when you
decide to tell people that you love in
your life about those said things you
know it's a part of your like story this
happens to be a good thing usually it's
like something sad or like something
major um honestly like money really does
change people like I'm sorry I would
wait I think you should continue to wait
as well I think there will be not like
you're lying you're not lying it's a Lie
by Omission but it's not a lie I think
that
um you should wait and I do think there
will be a moment where you feel like
completely comfortable and accepted by
this person and I think it's better to
have waited too long than to have told
too early agree with that
so I'm going to be cautious here you
could tell a lot by his reaction when
you do tell him which is a great litness
test yeah and also though I'm wondering
if you guys split things or if he pays
for everything because like as a
heteronormative woman I was all about
like a guy paying for [__] everything
regardless of situation now of course
I'm with a woman and I'm like the bread
winner so whatever whatever but like I
just feel like if he is like shelling
out [__] Mac Daddy money and you're
sitting there like on a pile of gold
that might piss him off but I also don't
want you on do like chivalry yeah no
don't say anything like for real and get
yourself a prenup I'm sure he's a nice
guy but if you do get engaged like
protect your lottery wins like you have
to that's not even a question don't do
not be stupid and you can also do
something in a prenup where it's like
everything that you had before the
marriage is yours after we're good after
it's and if you choose to co-mingle
right that's the word then like it
becomes like joint property but I
definitely would wait wait I I think you
wait until I wonder how about this have
you said I love you yet I'm sure that
they have I don't think she would be
considering if she haven't wait a year
yeah honestly like I don't think being
together with someone for a year before
sharing that kind of information is that
crazy I agree better to wait too long
than to you know pre prematurely
ejaculate I'm trying to think when I've
like told Tay about like money stuff in
our relationship took a really long time
money is I don't have millions I want
everyone to know that no but money's
funny money's really really bad actually
wait that's my advice and see how your
life is without him knowing it's there
right cuz that's when you're really
going to tell the person that you're
with all right are you ready for our
next one yes hey Jackson turd I need
some advice specifically from Claudia
because I too have a husband who doesn't
support women in Reading in writing I'm
dead I do have a problem I used to love
reading as a teenager but I fell out of
it because life got in the way during Co
I started reading again and I prefer
smut books you know what smut is oh hell
yeah okay um my husband says that I'm
basically reading porn and he is
uncomfortable with it he believes that
I'm thinking of other men picturing
myself as the female characters how do I
explain for him that this is truly just
a hobby for me I'm a stay-at-home mom
four it's the only thing that I do for
me he feels as though it's a form of
cheating how do I convince him that it's
really innocent make him read a book
that's a lot girl no like honestly I and
I feel like this I when I read a profile
of Colleen Hoover in the New York Times
because she really got like romance
novels back in popular culture and like
accepted as literature not as like this
dumb hobby for women um and I'm really
like a I get like annoyed when people
like discount romance novels like first
of all it's the same someone reads
Twilight to like Escape into Fantastical
realism magical realism like reading
romance novels is valid first of all
second of all I think if your husband
read one he might understand like
they're really good also and I can't
believe I'm saying this the consant
prude but like also like does my wife
watch porn I honestly don't know I'm
going to if I had to like bet I'd say
probably and like does she masturbate
and I'm not
yes like you're allowed like even if it
is porn which it's not but even if it
were it's not and it's certainly not a
form of cheating what a nerd it's
definitely not a form of cheating I
don't know I just feel like he like he
is so dead ass wrong it's beyond he's so
dead ass wrong and honestly like you
being a stay-at-home mom four like is
probably like I can't imagine a harder
job like in my in the entire world I
don't think anything is harder than that
and if you have found something that
makes you happy like please do not stop
honestly I do I actually feel like this
is a hill worth dying on like it's
important to you and it should be
important to him and he's being really
dumb and small-minded and this is such a
classic man thing to think such a man
thing you're so dumb like you don't even
know like the joy that reading brings
and I also want to know speaking of porn
does he watch porn right now we're going
to go there now we are going to go there
and now we've said
it so let's investigate every little
thing you do you read you look you watch
you're so perfect hi Pious on this
mountain of shaming me and actually I
would argue that smut book like really
um awaken the like it can really Inspire
women in their relationships it gives
you ideas it gets you you know lubed up
yes I honestly I feel like it's
beneficial for marriages that maybe have
had like you know a sexual rut yes I I'm
a big believer in the power of smut and
don't let your husband tell you
otherwise he's a dumb
ogre okay ready for our third and final
one yes please hey girly swires I
recently decided I want to get work on
my chin and jaw done I gathered the
information I presented it all to my
husband who's a very loving generous
precious gem of a man his response
definitely worth spending that money to
look
prettier he meant it in the nicest way
but his response really should have been
something like you're the most gorgeous
woman just the way you are but of course
do whatever you want to makes you happy
I need you to say it again to me what he
said definitely worth spending that
money to look prettier is he being
sarcastic I don't think so said like he
meant he thought he was saying something
nice now like I'm supportive right he
was trying like now part of me doesn't
want to do it because of his response
although I know that's silly since I
really want to have it done right would
love some perspective well as somebody
who's got her chin and jawline on let me
tell you it was hands down the best
thing I ever did it was a lot of money
for me and I was like you know what I
don't care like and I have not once
regretted getting it not once regretted
spending the money honestly I couldn't
have spent the money on anything better
so from the POV who from someone whose
chin and jaw really bothered them just
know you will be happy on the other end
just know that but now with the husband
if his intentions were in the right
place like I don't think you can be mad
or like really take what he said into
consideration so here's the thing not
doing it because of his response his
response was asked by the way yeah but
he didn't mean it he he short circuited
he got confused men are so that's like
kind of the me the message of today's
dear Clos like men are so mentally
unwell they're not okay so and we
honestly we have to like take care of
them like the little babies that they
are like Tim like Tim it was honestly
nice of you to run it by him like that
you're going to get it done but you
didn't need his permission and like you
should 100 % still do it yeah he short
circuited so here's the thing knocking
it done is like the epitome of cutting
your nose off to spite your face
literally or you're keeping your chin
not cutting it off like you're just
going to punish yourself in the long run
you wanted this before him it's not like
he looked at you and said hey chinless
go get a chin yeah hey your chin looks
bad is there anything we can do about
that chin hey Jay Leno hey
jeno so you should definitely do it but
I also have a partner who's very like I
really want to get stuffed done with my
teeth I definitely like anticipate like
a facelift at some point in life and
Taylor is like insane about it she's
like she's like a guy too and it's so
annoying but let me tell you how I used
to be like I'm going to get BOTOX and
lip filler and now I just go and he
literally doesn't even notice exactly so
it's better to ask for forgiveness and
permission so even though he said
something stupid at least he's
supportive yeah you could have a partner
like ours that says no yeah or like a
partner you know money also is a factor
in this for a lot of women in like
hetero relationships if they're stay-at
home moms husband they're like well no
you can't put that on the credit card
it's literally Financial abuse like I
had a friend that got a boob job and it
was like a it was a thing right exactly
but now he loves them right I mean boobs
I'm surprised any man would fight I know
I'm literally well he loved her as she
was and she was like I look like Kevin
McAllister shirt sweet that's sweet but
stop that's the thing though I think the
intention of the part the right answer
is always what are you talking about I
don't even see that it looks perfect but
do whatever you want exactly you're
perfect as is but whatever you want I
support yeah My Life Won't fully begin
until the day comes where I get my boobs
done you know I let's let's do a BOGO
I'll go in with you okay I'm doing a
reduction and a lift when when I'm done
breastfeeding my children who don't
exist yet okay and I'm like holding off
my life for these kids who I don't even
know isn't it so annoying it's
disgusting my kids are already stealing
my money from me I wanted to go on a
romantic Tri trip with my wife and she
was like no for the kid you really you
want me to love this thing you you've
already started the financial journey to
Childhood correct yeah and we're
starting to move like my office in our
apartment up to the shipping container
like that's like getting the nurser kind
of primed yeah no you're definitely like
a year what would you say like I would
like to hold out until you're ready to
go I know that would be so great if we
talk about trauma bonding I know [__]
you're not even the one who has to get
pregnant I can't even talk to you about
this you didn't even know how good you
have it your wife wants to do everything
and is like more than happy to let you
just lay and drink wine I could just
like not have a child ever no you're
going to be an amazing Mom oh my my God
thank you you're actually extremely
nurturing and maternal and I'm I
actually love this journey for you for
real for real for real like I have I
know you like doubt your abilities a lot
that's just cuz like you're like fishing
for compliments you it's not true I'm
just really worried about money I know
I'm money obsessed and I still will
never get over the fact that somebody
listens to the toast on the lottery I'm
so jealous of you can you send me money
okay here's the thing Taylor there's
never you even people who have a lot of
money don't have enough money for kids
like it's all relative and you make it
work you just do I just sometimes wish
like I had to talk with wasbin and I was
like hey I'm a lesbian but you're a nice
guy how about we stay married I can have
this girlfriend on the side yeah and we
can have like this weird throtle
yeah yeah I love that I feel like we
helped a lot of people today yeah and I
love seeing you thank you so much
seriously for being here so much I love
being here I love The Toasters I love
the community if you liked what you
heard here today Taylor does her own
Daily Show an hour a day it's at uh
patreon it's a very good price for a
Daily Show $6 .95 thank you uh Taylor
patreon.com thet tayor ster show you got
it and follow you on Instagram Taylor
ster Taylor ster and please listen to
taste or Taylor it's free free podcast
she does every week I've been on it a
bunch of times Brian's on it Ben's on it
Margo's on it everyone's on it you're
exporting my whole family lit love it
it's called Taste of Taylor you can get
it anywhere you get your podcast thank
you so much for listening to the toast
and londay Morning Show where we deliver
the past five stories you need to know
everybody the Friday on YouTube so if
you're watching this on YouTube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
as podcast any where podcast can be
found Spotify search public radio I rast
box all the places podcast find us the
toar sunning and wickedly talented we
are hope you guys have an amazing hum
day we'll see you tomorrow we are in
studio with a special guest host who's
never been on the show it is fibula well
his name is Connor but everyone calls
him fibula we'll see you then love you
bye